das duell gegen beiden was für ein krimi
meine damen und herren ich wissen sie
inzwischen mehr als ich aber während wir
hier aufzeichnen kann ich ihnen nicht
sicher sagen wer gewonnen hat tendenz
eindeutig beiden schon klar
schafft er so ist tatsächlich ins weiße
haus oder klagt trump am ende doch
erfolgreich auf eigenbedarf nach vier
jahren mit dem man kann einen ja
eigentlich nichts mehr schocken
aber wenn sich einer in der wahlnacht
während er hinten liegt und millionen
stimmen noch gar nicht ausgezählt sind
zum sieger erklärt dann ist das schon
eine neue dimension mann oh mann
und als der aufstrebende junge diktator
gestern abend noch einen draufgelegt hat
gab es bei den kollegen von cnbc in den
usa eine absolute tv sternstunde
gänsehaut oder jetzt schon mein liebster
fernsehmoment eva schramm sagt in
staaten wo ich vorne liege sofort
aufhören zu zählen aber wo ich hinten
liege unbedingt weitermachen und briefe
alles ebisch ist war da kriegt ja kaum
stimmen in schramms eigenen worten was
für ein erbärmlicher looser anwälte und
gerichte sollen sie eine hochverdiente
niederlage irgendwie in einen sieg um
klagen
wie kann man in einer so explosiven
stimmung ohne jeden beweis von
wahlbetrug fasel ist unverantwortlich
vor allem bei nächte tram fans ja nur
noch seinen tweets glauben die
wahlbehörden vor ort bemühen sich aktiv
um transparenz wollen anschuldigungen
von wahlfälschung entkräften aber nicht
bei allen kommt das an
kriminelle beiden familie spielt die
wahl und die medien vertuschen das
barbecue bier und freiheit kann ich
eigentlich alles unterschreiben
brandgefährliche situation in den usa
jeden tag stehen sich da jetzt auf den
straßen schreiende trump leute und
gegner gegenüber manche bewaffnet da
kann wirklich jedes falsche wort
schlimme folgen haben sein sohn donner
junior hier bei einem
auftritt in georgia wettert gegen
angeblichen schummeleien das beste für
die usa sei wenn sein vater den totalen
krieg gegen die wahl eröffne jo super
idee am besten ihr schmeißt atombomben
auf einer auszählung zentren wo ihr
hinten liegt die tramps den junior von
beruf sohn mit der aura eines zu
gekürzten gebrauchtwagenhändlers aber
auch so einer kann leider leute
aufhetzen demokratie geht nur mit
friedlicher machtübergabe ist doch klar
und wie konnte das überhaupt noch so
knapp werden was muss man denn noch
machen um da erdrutschartig abgewählt zu
werden
tatsache ist wohl die amerikaner leben
inzwischen in zwei verschiedenen
realitäten und in einer davon ist es
offensichtlich egal wenn man eine
pandemie so katastrophal mies gemanagt
hat wie donald trump phd tor lian der
control wir haben es total unter
kontrolle alles wird gut das hat donald
trump im januar noch über das kona virus
gesagt eine von über 20.000 lügen die er
während seiner amtszeit erzählt hat um
die seit kurzem jeder auf dieser wand
nachlesen kann programm
da hat er ja seine versprochene mauer im
schnitt mehr als 310 lügen pro tag das
schaffen nicht nur wir bei den
öffentlich rechtlichen
richtig gut lief es für trump übrigens
in florida
viele fragen sich was war ausgerechnet
da sein geheimnis wieso hat er so gut
abgeschnitten ausgerechnet in der latino
community ganz einfach sein wahlspot für
die war leider gut
[Musik]
wahnsinn oder hasst dieser rhythmus
ausmacht ich behaupte freunde so kann
man fast jeden kandidaten funky mache
sogar die alle aller farbloses ja so
punktet scholz bei den kickers aber das
nur am rande
wie geht das weiter in den vereinigten
staaten joe biden hat mit seinen 77
jahren über 73 millionen stimmen geholt
mehr als jeder andere kandidat in der
geschichte des landes
laut umfragen haben ihnen die meisten
allerdings nur gewählt um trump zu
verhindern was ein sehr guter grund ist
keine frage immerhin will er versuchen
sagt der präsident aller amerikaner zu
sein
viel glück von dieser stelle aus er wird
in jedem fall sympathisch wenn auch
manchmal ein wenig billig ist doch egal
irgendwelche frauen hauptsache joe ist
schoss ehemann für trump anhänger ist
der jo tatsächlich ein gefährlicher
sozial ist was ganz lustig ist denn der
job war jahrzehnte senator von delaware
einer berüchtigten steueroase und hat
seine schützte hand immer über die
finanzindustrie gehalten wie das
sozialisten halt so machen
ich fürchte ja viele amerikaner wissen
gar nicht was sozialismus ist vielleicht
muss man denen das noch mal erklären
pass mal auf tram fern sozialismus ist
wenn dir die kinder nach der geburt
weggenommen werden und dann direkt zur
armee mist wenn du nur urlaub an der
ostsee machen darfst und zwar
ausschließlich nackt wenn der staat eine
mauer baut damit keiner mehrere aus kann
und natürlich wenn es keine bananen
geben das nennen wir den real
existierenden sozialismus was die us
demokraten wollen also eine bezahlbare
krankenversicherung für alle und das
zumindest babys keine automatischen
waffen tragen dürfen das nennt man ein
zivilisiertes land kurze nachhilfe die
zeit muss sein
joe biden im weißen haus was würde sich
dann konkret ändern
vor allem wenn er keine senatsmehrheit
hat fragen über fragen und eine heikle
woche auch für unsere bundesregierung
angela merkels verhältnis zu trump ist
ja bekanntlich eher so mittel herzlich
sag ich mal meine der präsident war in
vier jahren nicht einmal zum
staatsbesuch in berlin
gut jetzt muss man fairerweise sagen bis
letzte woche gab es in berlin auch keine
vernünftigen flughafen wo die airforce
waren hätte landen können
sie hörten den definitiv letzten pr gag
in der heute show diesmal aber echt
jetzt versprochen
absolut was ich eigentlich sagen will
schramm mag uns nicht wie also reagiert
man in berlin auf das amerikanische
wahlchaos die kanzlerin dazu keine
presse statement ein
der außenminister sagte ein geplantes
presse statement ab der bundespräsident
schweigt beste rede von steinmeier die
je gehört habe
demnächst in ihrem zdf die schönsten
lehrern stehpulte deutschlands sowie
schalt mal live nach berlin zu unserer
reporterin valerie niehaus von hier aus
wie hat denn die groko diesen wahlkrimi
erlebt naja also die nacht von dienstag
auf mittwoch war schon hart
ein wechselbad der gefühle offiziell
darf sich die kanzlerin ja nicht in den
us wahlkampf einmischen
aber wenn sie mit ihrem mann vor dem
fernseher sitzt ist sie natürlich privat
und als sie da gesehen hat wie deutlich
der beiden in den letzten umfragen vor
öffnung der wahllokale führt da gab es
durchaus emotionen und die ein oder
andere flasche rotkäppchensekt ja und
dann kam halt das ergebnis von florida
völlig ausgerastet und am ende ganz
natürlich professor sauer abgekriegt die
nerven lagen blank auch den rest der
woche wird es jetzt wirklich beiden oder
nicht joe biden ist 77 jahre alt der hat
zwar damals als vizepräsident von obama
die merkel kennen gelernt aber sie
inzwischen natürlich längst wieder
vergessen
also hat sie sich immer noch einmal
vorgestellt und dabei kurz erklärt wer
die deutschen sind im logo is as the
germans du kennst uns noch persönlich
aus weltkriegen wie weltkrieg 1 und
weltkrieg 2 heute zahlen wir ungern
unseren vollen nato beitrag und fans
total super wenn die usa es trotzdem
weiter beschützen
aber da war schon eingeschlafen
wirklich furchtbar angespannte woche
fürs politische berlin
allein die vorstellung noch mal vier
jahre trumpf haben sie gehört wie der im
wahlkampf endspurt über deutschland
geredet hat erstens völlig richtig
zweitens er nennt uns in einem atemzug
mit iran und china
deutschland ist jetzt offiziell ein
schurkenstaat wir sind wieder die bösen
wie in den alten indiana jones filmen
effekt beruht aber sagen sie mal mit
einem präsidenten beiden im weißen haus
da sind wir doch wieder bierfest träumen
weiter welche auch die demokraten
verlangen dass deutschland viel mehr für
rüstung ausgibt und wollen uns unsere
geliebte nord stream zwei pipeline
verbieten
wir wollen doch einfach nur in ruhe
unsere teuren stinke autos verkaufen und
das gleichzeitig irgendeines von den
erwachsenen ländern auf uns aufpasst ist
das denn zu viel verlangt man was machen
wir denn jetzt ganz einfach deutschland
braucht einen neuen sugar daddy und da
müssen wir uns wohl oder übel in unserem
neuen freundeskreis umsehen
mein vorschlag wir bewerben uns heute
noch als westlichste provinz der
volksrepublik china
[Musik]
die heute-show grüßt ihren neuen
machthaber die gute idee valerie niehaus
meine prognose in vier jahren werden
viele us bürger wahrscheinlich fragen
zählen wir immer weiter stimmen oder
machen wir jetzt einfach neuwahl
so oder so hat uns die älteste und
lustigs der demokratie der welt in
dieser woche wirklich unzählige schöne
fernsehstunden geschenkt aufmerksam
beobachtet von friedrich küppersbusch
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch bundestagswahl im fernsehen
das kennen wir von der von der
hochrechnung bis zur berliner wundersam
mit küsschen und popo abwischen vier
stunden dann ist das ding aber durch
kriegen wir dahin in deutschland
höchste zeit also dass wir television
story tonen titan dem ami mal zeigen wo
die lampe hängt den usa gilt ja so
traditionell im fernsehen eher schlicht
besticht
[Musik]
oder mio
herzlich willkommen zur phoenix wahl
nach stille nacht ja ich bisky völlig
überraschend für viele deutsche sender
bars diese woche in den usa zu
präsidentschafts wahlen gekommen
die ard zum beispiel konnte gerade noch
drei billy-regale schlecht zusammen
löten dann ging es auch schon los mit
graf zahl jörg schönenborn und der hatte
ein ass im ärmel zu klaus kokol heißt ja
ganze 11 das war meine schulter schon
mal den lagern zugeordnet da sehen sie
jetzt dunkelrote sind die staaten nach
texas geht immer mit der schulter auf
und arizona ganz lustig warum steht da
texas in montana gab's ja mein ärmel
wieder texas in unserer simulation steht
joe biden immer noch sehr viel besser da
wir bewegen uns ein stück südlich nach
oregon mein ärmel will immer texas ist
lustig immer wenn ich hier mit dem
ellbogen vorbeikomme öffnet sich texas
sehr richtig vorwitzig jörg in texas
gibt es übrigens noch die todesstrafe
ich mein ja nur neu dabei diesmal
streaming shows wird war bild tv eine
moderierende selbsthilfegruppe viele
musterte sich durch zwölf stunden und
bewies dabei erfrischend dass sie auch
auf der glatze locken drehen kann
das ist eine familie solider
familienmitglieder seine haare färben
und deswegen seien die auch immer so
unterschiedlich weil wenn man genau
darauf achtet dann haben die oben immer
ein bisschen eine andere farbe als unten
wird nicht gerne unten eine andere farbe
als oben vielleicht neuer trend nun gilt
es friesen gewinner der nacht für mich
eindeutig norbert röttgen peter altmaier
und alexander graf lambsdorff die drei
autos spender torkelten durch alle
sendungen von ard zdf rtl n tv und
erzwang am frühen morgen mit
waffengewalt zutritt zum kinderkanal
kurz nach 2 nachdem der swing state
florida an die republikaner ging rief
trump sich dann auf allen sendern live
aus zum florida branche nein noch
durchgeknallter
somit war seeger sogar digitale
netzwerke die sonst jeden goebbels
durchwinken rücken jetzt aber doch mal
waren hinweise ein
die wahl wird noch ausgezählt es gibt
keinen erklärten gewinner
was ist würde ein nicht bundeskanzlerin
merkel machen wenn zwei männer
gleichzeitig behaupten us präsident zu
sein
wer redet dann mit wem bild tv hat er
schon mal eine idee donald und fritz
kämpfen gegen das establishment gegen
die realität und erleben jeden abend
eine windmühle und zwar in dem
paralleluniversum in dem tram
präsidenten märz kanzler und bilde eine
zeitung guten abend über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]